I want to tell you about the Christmas
party we had a Christmas party look yeah
you could tell me about it the food's a
little too fancy you know what I know it
is the food's awesome here they go dude
first of all when you walk do you come
in what about what please I'm begging
you it's amazing
do not listen to you have a full buffet
first of all kinds of things what they
cheeseburger too fancy we're the buffalo
wings too fancy am I gonna sound
ungrateful if I can be honest I mean the
truth that number one their way
aggressive with the food the the people
they're like I'm trying to talk to
people in every satisfied that's because
I said to them I don't want anybody
searching for food let the food fly like
a new guy I don't want whatever the [ __ ]
this is there's too much good foods you
could say money and put out potato chips
and pizza and these guys were mad don't
invite me to any of your party [ __ ]
horrible serve some chips banks I'll get
out of the house just for that party I
love that Will's an aristocrat now that
you'll only go to parties where there's
[ __ ] it's a treat Avion is it okay
even though I eat a certain way all the
time to once a year want to have a treat
and so I find this to be a tree I'm
trying to make it special
does that make me like some sort of like
I'm an aristocrat no I like good food
once in a while is that of crime well
then people we don't have anything to
eat at the party that's all I'm saying
did you ever see a sushi bar open like
that
I don't eat that you don't eat steak you
don't eat fish you don't eat not chicken
pasta dude I'm not saying you got to
worry about me I feel like me
to me next year I'll have the party a
Papa John's it's a good party I'm not
saying any different just the food sucks
and everything is in my you know I don't
think Dave I was wow I'm shocked
anything cuz everything is there one
picky [ __ ] either when you raise your
hand what does it mean that we're all
okay how are you eating man Howard this
guy put salt on chicken nuggets so like
oh man Howard you know how some people
keep a salt shaker on their desk yeah I
want to show you my met salt shaker is a
giant the whole box of Morton's sauce so
you're addicted to salt no wonder so of
course you do you put salt on each yeah
nobody does not salty enough already in
that bed he put salt on Kentucky Fried
Chicken oh my god I've watched him do it
with me are you kidding me is this room
really you I don't want to [ __ ]
lecture me on healthy eating Jay you
know planet are we living on and I'm
healthiest person on this off if you're
putting that much salt on your food I
guarantee you're in for a disaster you
stole a young guy
I pray have a deficiency or something so
my body needs tastebuds are so
unsophisticated you need to drown out
the taste of the food how do you ever
put salt on bacon oh my god oh my god oh
my god I pray to God salt
I was surprised cuz you're a vegan
there's no vegan I'm not a vegan baby
like why do you say I'm a vegan no there
was nothing V because most of that crowd
is not vegan there's vegetarian dishes
yeah it was salads I liked when Benji
suddenly becomes a vegan except when
he's not there was no garbanzo you're
doing juicy you're not vegan all the
time I know that why don't they have
vegan it's only the bus peoples balls
when he's out and about he's not eating
vegan at your wedding yeah it's a bust
your balls to be game for the vegan
twice your wedding yeah and your [ __ ]
here's a question we're all havin and
asked me to a vegan meal when are you
for the break when you flew to LA and
said she couldn't go when you flew to LA
did you request a vegan meal a lot of
planes don't have meals now trust me
he's a vegan for when he you know when
can bust balls but we ain't never swear
no huge tubs Egan to bust balls I
wouldn't have brought that up because
you're not a vegan you eat non vegan
right
so don't cuss at the party and start
talking about B you know I'm saying I
was surprised you don't have to be a
vegan what that's a good day that for
you not to be a vegan if you were a
vegan all the time I'd hear your point
but since there are times you are a
vegan and times you are not a vegan how
about that night
go full-on non vegan I don't like to eat
meat in front of other people to buy
I've been taking home take it home in a
bed take it the best yeah go home I
actually remember I couldn't eat I was
wearing a girdle